in this example how can get tell if B
Prime and B double prime are modified
versions of B or if the users just
deleted B and wrote entirely new lines
in the same area rather than expending a
lot of effort trying to figure this sort
of thing out get just notes that the
lines are different and goes from there
so how does get know whether or not
there should be a merge conflict
consider the following two examples in
both cases we start with two identical
copies at the same file in the first
case two different contributors add new
functions to the bottom of the files
these are different functions that don't
interact with each other and have
nothing to do with one another however
in the second case two different
contributors add different
implementations of the same function
with different names in the first case
you pretty clearly want both functions
to be included but in this second
situation you probably only want one
version of the function probably
whichever one is either more memory
efficient or faster depending on what
you're going for but get can't really
tell these two options apart it would
take some pretty sophisticated machine
learning to do this and this is only one
possible scenario making it smart enough
to figure out all the possible cases
where you'd want to Auto merge would be
a huge undertaking so instead it just
assumes that if you're merging together
two commits that have changes in the
same general area the author's will want
to know about it and have the chance to
figure out for themselves which change
to keep this decision to ask the user
whenever there's any ambiguity at all
does sometimes lead to situations where
it seems really obvious to you as an
expert on the content how to resolve the
conflict the git brings it to your
attention anyway while this may be
annoying it's significantly better than
if get tried to guess too often which
could lead to weird conglomerate changes
that don't really make any sense and
probably wouldn't compile a run